[Narrator] This is the AMC
on East Illinois Street in Chicago.
They're playing 17 movies.
But you actually have 21 options
because there's so many formats.
Should you see "Toy
Story 4" in 3D? Digital?
Hang on, what's Dolby?
And why does it cost 18 bucks?
Which one do you pick?
If you've bought a movie
ticket in the last decade,
you've seen this:
a bunch of different options,
each with dramatically different prices.
The same movie is being screened,
but there are a lot of
ways it can be projected.
In order to figure out why
there are so many formats,
we need to find out what
these actually mean.
It's more complicated than
the five names you see listed.
Let's start with the basics.
Standard, sometimes just
referred to as digital:
This is your average
movie-theater experience,
found anywhere from Regal to
a small independent theater.
Then there's 3D, the one with the glasses,
usually branded as RealD 3D.
These projectors use polarized light
to create the illusion of depth,
which supposedly makes
the film more immersive.
But a lot of people just
find it disorienting.
3D movies aren't as
popular as they once were.
In fact, in 2018, the MPAA reported
a 20% year-over-year decrease
in the global 3D box office.
All right, let's ditch those 3D glasses
and check out the newest
format to hit theaters,
Dolby.
Dolby Digital Cinemas, made by Dolby,
can be found at AMC theaters.
It uses dual 4K laser projectors.
That's four times more resolution
than a standard theater projector.
These projectors produce
super crisp images
with deep blacks and bright highlights,
at 500 times the contrast ratio
and twice the brightness
of a standard projector.
Dolby is the best HDR you
can get in the theater.
High dynamic range means
really bright highlights
and really dark blacks.
Dolby Cinema images
appear less muddy or gray
compared to the traditional projectors.
Overall, it's supposed to
create a more realistic image.
And it reminds you, over
and over, with this video...
Ad announcer: Fire becomes fire.
Sun becomes sun.
[Narrator] Yeah, we get it.
But the biggest difference with
Dolby is their sound system.
They call it Dolby Atmos.
All movie theaters use surround sound.
That means using more speakers
so the viewer can hear
sounds from the direction
they're supposed to be
coming from onscreen,
like behind you, or to your right.
But Dolby Atmos is like
super surround sound.
It uses many more speakers
to completely surround the viewer.
There are even speakers on the ceiling
and transducers, which
produce bass under the seats.
There's also a version of
Dolby that offers 3D movies.
Thanks to the higher-quality projectors,
the image actually appears brighter
than with traditional 3D.
And then there's IMAX.
You've probably heard of IMAX,
because it's actually been
around since the '70s.
But this can get a little confusing,
because unlike Dolby, not
every IMAX theater is the same.
Unique to IMAX is its huge screen,
which is bigger than any other
format, up to 40% larger,
and it uses an aspect ratio
that's taller than other theaters.
With some movies, this means
you're seeing more of the image
instead of black bars on the
top and bottom of the frame.
The newest IMAX theaters
use dual 4K laser projectors
and have an upgraded sound system.
But if you buy an IMAX ticket,
you might not be getting
your money's worth.
Depending on your theater,
you may be getting what
some refer to as Lie-MAX.
These Lie-MAX, ahem,
IMAX Experience theaters
have a smaller screen and
lower-resolution projectors.
It's not clear just
from buying your ticket
if your theater is IMAX
with laser or Lie-MAX,
but you can check this
website to find out.
Like Dolby, some theaters
also offer IMAX 3D.
But if you're walking
out of your IMAX movie
wondering why the screen
felt smaller than last time,
you might spot one more logo.
RPX is Regal's own
large-format experience,
offering bigger screens, newer projectors,
and an updated sound system.
That list probably sounds familiar by now.
Basically, RPX will look and sound better
than a standard movie theater.
But it's not as premium as
Dolby or IMAX with laser.
Oh yeah, there's also 4DX,
but, uh, that's its own thing.
This is a lot of information.
But that's actually just digital.
Some films offer special screenings
where you can view actual
film being projected.
"Dunkirk" and "The Hateful Eight"
offered 70-millimeter screenings.
70mm is huge, more than six times bigger
than standard 35mm film.
There's also 70mm IMAX,
which is how IMAX first started.
Some moviegoers enjoy film projections
because it creates a more organic
and less sterile image
compared to digital.
Besides 70mm, some theaters
still offer 35mm film projections,
but these are usually for
special events, not new releases.
So yeah, there's a lot
more to these screenings
than just their names.
Here are a few takeaways
from all of those specs:
Bigger screens, newer projectors,
and larger sound systems
usually make a better viewing experience.
But if IMAX and Dolby are both
bigger and higher-quality,
which is better?
Well, it depends.
If you want the biggest
screen size you can get,
you want IMAX.
With some screens over 80 feet wide,
IMAX is way bigger than Dolby.
Just make sure it's IMAX with laser.
But if you're an audiophile who has to get
the best sound possible, go with Dolby.
Dolby Atmos is noticeably more immersive
than traditional surround sound.
Dolby theaters are also usually newer,
so chances are it will
be better maintained.
But both Dolby and IMAX
have better quality control
over the sound and image
than a standard theater.
Dolby does offer a crisper, brighter image
with deeper blacks than IMAX.
But both IMAX with laser
and Dolby look great.
The average moviegoer probably
wouldn't notice a difference
without seeing these images side by side.
But IMAX theaters also
have a taller screen,
so if you're watching a movie
like "Avengers: Endgame"
that was specifically shot for IMAX,
you'll see more of the image
instead of having black
bars on the top and bottom.
But projection isn't everything.
If you're going to watch a
three-hour "Avengers" movie,
you want to be comfortable.
Certain theaters offer reclining seats,
food trays, or paired seats.
These are a deal-breaker for some people.
The specifics will vary
theater to theater,
but you can usually check online
before buying your ticket.
Obviously, all of these
features won't come cheap.
If you want to see a newer,
higher-quality format,
your ticket is going to cost more.
Now, if all you wanted was to see a movie
on a hot summer day, this
might seem silly to you.
But some people are passionate
about how they watch a movie.
And who can blame them?
Movie tickets have hit an average price
of over $9 nationwide,
and in big cities it's
even more expensive.
If you're paying a bunch of money,
you want the best experience possible.
All of these formats give
moviegoers more choice.
If you just want to see a
comedy with some friends,
standard digital is probably fine.
But if you're seeing the big blockbuster
you've been waiting a year for,
it might be worth the extra money
to see it in the biggest format available.
Different genres lend
themselves to different formats.
And these formats give directors
and cinematographers more choices too.
Christopher Nolan shot parts of "Dunkirk"
with an IMAX camera,
which made those exterior
shots feel large and epic,
while the interior shots
felt tight and confined.
The taller IMAX aspect ratio was used
to add more impact to the story.
And sound designers are
able to be more detailed
and creative when using a
system like Dolby Atmos.
All of these formats give
filmmakers the opportunity
to tell their story the
way they want to tell it.
Of course, it helps the theaters too.
Formats like Dolby and IMAX are a reason
to go to the theater
instead of watching at home.
But whether you want crispy
Dolby or grainy 35mm,
you've got a lot of options.
And that's a good thing.
Imagine if 3D was the only
way you could see a movie.